[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to author
record where we
talk about whatever we want essay
and uh anthony you showing us how to
pick our teeth with the two
you know i'm just trying to be american
i didn't know that was asian culture to
do it like this i was just saying
americans i thought it was just classy
he said it's american culture i don't
know
is it you guys don't do this show me a
toothpick it's asian i never
thank my teeth with the toothpick anyway
i i always pick my teeth in front of a
mirror too
because i have to see it i have to like
dig around yeah i usually just get floss
if i have something stuck
like this floss is a lot easier so
so this works i was taught to do it you
have to focus
like this right but i never knew that
you'd go like this
a little closer to the camera though
that is polite i just no it's because he
was also
he was also covering his nose so that's
why i was like oh you want to do it like
this
not like this but like you're really
like
that's impressive it's not easy it's not
easy
i'm sorry i don't know you know what my
favorite one is the cinnamon flavored
i just put it in my mouth like this and
i feel so cool wait what
yeah wait there's flavored i think are
you serious those are the ones that help
like tea tree oil toothpicks those are
cool
those kind of help smokers like stop
smoking because it gives you like a
sensation in your mouth when you're like
chewing and flavor releases
it like helps you stop smoking what if
they had a beef jerky version
i think that's just i guess i think you
got to swallow i think it gets in your
teeth yeah beef jerky is the opposite of
a toothpick
oh you're right [ __ ] in your teeth you
see that guy on tick tock who like has
this method of like flicking it too
yes it goes into i saw that did you try
it nah
i don't have to take this i don't know
our walls are [ __ ] up anyway if you'll
get the toothpick so
it's something like this he'll get the
toothpick he places it here he does this
and then he'll flick it and then it just
sticks like a [ __ ]
ninja then yeah no way
yeah and it's sick i'll try it again
look it up later poison and kill people
isn't that what all the hong kong flicks
had like they had like flicks
yeah the hong kong they had the
acupuncture
and then just be like oh they
acupuncture through flicking yeah you
ever see that movie kissing the dragon
with
jet li oh yeah the whole premise of the
movie but after you watch it now
you're just like oh why martial arts
movies do not age
well some of them don't i don't think
what are you talking about
who was always age well [ __ ] i did old
school like slow ones the slow ones age
12
geez we're out of this conversation but
then there's some like that
i don't know what do you mean it doesn't
age well i don't know if it's like super
cop's pretty cool
that's like that's a comfort movie yeah
it's super cop
time consumption hong kong action film
that's what it is yeah there's a genre
of martial arts films that i feel like
don't age very well
because i think nowadays there's so much
mma in our faces
well i don't know maybe maybe it's just
me maybe you're just educated bro
you just gotta give it like ten more
years it'll be good again it
like this you know they kind of throw
their arms this way rather than like
throwing straight
punches you see the skill of this guy
bro
you get all the credit you taught us nah
that's all casey dude that's not casey
he was for sure doing this before yeah
like this one of these guys
it's not a kung fu movie but i was
watching the matrix
yeah and i was still like still holds up
the way that they fight so
cool the way that the fighting style is
like a kung fu movie
yeah there's a line the whole line is i
know kung fu
yeah it's a comfy movie and then they
swim around
i use the cables he's like i know sci-fi
he didn't say i know mma that's true he
goes i know
kung fu and he's like kind of
questioning
him he's like show me yeah i still want
to believe that one day
somebody will bust out real kung fu like
the movies
and then like kind of like that dude
style bender yeah like uh
or that uh you mean like in street
fighting like in real life yeah in real
life
you can't use kung fu in real life is
that bad you can't i think what he's
talking about is when they like suddenly
start flying and jumping on bamboo trees
and stuff like that
how did you know you drop a cup and they
catch it you know that type of [ __ ]
you know he did not smell like the duke
in the car
into parallel parking like shaolin
soccer
speaking of the guy on tick tock did you
see the guy that can like uh
get off of a ledge and then he dips both
toes into the water and then comes back
in
no strings attached you know what's
talking about he does a lot of stuff
right you're like
real no we don't know water stuff i
don't know
it exists yeah it's in there yeah
because he went on the pawn and he
jumped back up
i don't know if he's being sarcastic
you're right no did i saw a father and
son
kung fu like uh thing on t tick tock it
was like a little bald boy and a bald
dad were they shaolin monks and they
were yeah shaolin monks but mexican or
something yeah
yeah they were like our worlds are
colliding
angeles that is maybe but maybe okay i'm
creating this backstory maybe there were
like latinos that like decided to do
kung fu
and then they went to china to like
study the real [ __ ]
i don't know but they weren't chinese
sounds legit the kid looks half though
yeah looks
like skateboarding down and drinking
ocean spray
he's part native american all right so
we don't claim him 100 i was just
describing this
with a cranberry juice he's wearing
cortez and [ __ ] all the time you know
that's why i know she's from east los
though wait so what did the
father and son do no they were doing
some sick ass kung fu moves
like like there was a temple in the
background your own question eventually
okay yeah i did
i forgot my own fantasies it wasn't
being sarcasm no thank god yeah okay
we're good it's a real thing yeah nice
no because i forgot about the
dude that jumps on the pond and he jumps
right back up
yeah and he does all these crazy ass
tricks
yeah that's true yeah so is it like like
how deep is the water is it like it's
one of those like toe taps it's like
when you like
you like spring and you jump and then
you like kick real quick
while you're still going up and then he
is touching a surface
he like jumps off the floor and while
he's still going upward he pumps his
legs
to tap the water and then comes back
down it looks like this
imagine if you jumped off a curb and
then you touch the concrete real quick
and bounce back up
yes it's a small it's a small i am i
think you could do it
dude you're hella graceful on casey
right now okay you got it you got to lie
down
on the floor oh they can't see it
anthony they can't see on the floor
i feel like i'm going to be pretty
entertained okay yeah i see me in the
camera
can they see him in the camera what i
gotta do is jump
off this tap him in the balls wait wait
wait wait wait wait
wait land back on the table all right
you ready wait wait the balls are
involved hold on a second let me think
about it i don't know
i really like those hey we're trying to
get pregnant don't you save your calm
no i did not freeze my clothes
that cable looks like it's gonna break
it's like here baby
did you see the technique though i
forfeit did you see the technique
you know we have this bag in the whole
session last year
now it's in this one no it's not
yeah how is it in there right here you
can see it what is that a pizza
bag yeah exactly no it's there oh
no you can't see it i'm good can you see
the why do we have bottles of water here
this is not the time to clean off this
is the time
table right next to joe and it's got
like everything on there from downey
wrinkle releaser to water like five
water bottles
nuts there's a kazoo back here scratch
or a band-aid
[ __ ] body get your water from
yesterday oh tattletail
take it on air right now drink it over
there chug chug
i don't know where that water came from
man this place is a mess dude someone's
got to clean this [ __ ] up
i mean most of it is your mestro on that
side
looking forward to your person here yeah
like joe has a lot of
90 of that stuff is yours you say mess
i say art collection i want you to show
us like what you have back here like
what kind of art instruments you have
like
okay well we said that art art auctions
stuff away again yeah okay
cause last time we came up and you guys
if you're on patreon you saw
that whole stuff happen we got a korean
barbecue grill
anthony you got some soundproof and the
water heater
all right you want more stuff yeah what
else you got um
you can't have none of this this is very
did he really give it to you or did you
take it back no no it's like we took it
home
yeah well wait for it wait for the text
it's gonna happen where he's gonna
remember and he's gonna want it back
yeah he kept the toaster oven tight
he's like wait hold on i give away the
toaster that's true
i'm like sometimes i'm like where did
that thing go and i'm like oh yeah tiff
has it hey you using it because i'll
take it back if you're not
it's happened it goes back and forth a
rice cooker
because they had two and i was like you
don't need two
i gave you that one you make a lot of
rice rice cooker two i was like all
right i mean it is yours you can have a
bag
so it's just a butter system in here you
know okay but no you can't say that
you give back her that's good use it
until you don't need it
i feel you what do you mean i like it
though i love community life you're
still using your car
by any chance you guys could do it to me
now you know i don't know you're biking
everywhere you know biking around i
don't care because
tiff gave me a microwave well no she
gave jk a microwave
and a christmas tree the microwave here
that's broken you guys it's not broken
okay the microwave here you guys don't
know how to [ __ ] finesse it he hasn't
used his debit card i heard
ever can i take it to me we can have it
oh you're also using our old
refrigerator because we gave it to aunt
christina and then you're using it
oh you are so essentially i'm using and
get and you guys are using my stuff
yes it gives me a lot of stress and you
know how i uh
un relieve my stress today's video is
brought to you by feels baby
cool so do you experience stress
especially when your friends don't want
to give back the things that you gave
them
yes or have anxiety when you give
all of your belongings out to all of
your friends knowing that they're going
to take good care of it
and one day you can get it back okay
chronic pain
from all the all the suffering that your
friends give you
because you you were carrying heavy
items like a refrigerator
we get it or have trouble sleeping
because you're worried about all your
belongings in your friends homes
stressful wait i thought we were dressed
you just gave me anxiety right now many
of us do personally
and okay i was searching for anything
that would help then i discovered feels
of course this is written but legit
though they did send me something
and i freaking love it what is feels
it's a premium cbd
delivered directly to your doorstep
feels naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness
and i know this for a fact because when
y'all stress me out
i get a little bit of the feels and i
put it in my mouth and i go bloop
bloop and i go oh i just chill out now
it was
it was a kesara okay so place a few
drops of feels
under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose is important
and everyone's dose is different me
personally
i drench my mouth in it so leave room to
experiment over the course of a week or
so
you may need to take more or less to get
the effects
you're after new to cbd fields offers a
free cbd hotline to help guide your
personal
experience fuels works naturally to help
you feel better there's no high hangover
or addiction
join the fields community to get fields
delivered to your door every month
you'll save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel anytime
feels has me feeling my best every day
and it can help you to become a member
today by going to fields.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order with free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com
slash off the record to become a member
and get
50 off automatically taking off your
first order with free shipping
fuels dot com slash off the record thank
you very much
okay dude
whatever will be will be
i am okay tell us about your diet i am
on a diet
and i i did a sugar cut i'm lying right
now because right now i'm drinking um
turn it around there we go there's uh
there's sugar in this drink
what the [ __ ] is going on i can't keep
up what's the diet
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
limited he asked me what kind of diet
he's cheating
okay quesadilla we moved on from me
giving and taking back from you guys
by the way i am going to clean up that
space and there's a lot of [ __ ] i need
to
unload there you go but here it is
thank you that's a big help
but uh yeah i i want to cut sugar out
it's hard to cut it out completely
because it's in all of our foods
but i think it's worse than like a lot
of other unhealthy [ __ ]
i realize sugar yeah no but tastes so
good i know right
what could be so bad about it yeah it
stays so good it don't matter
you have eczema right oh yeah i i'm
still trying to get rid of it and then
you did
a vegan cleanse and all these things and
then when you did an elimination diet it
helped out right well tell them what you
recently discovered
i realized my eczema is also caused by
[ __ ] fermented ass foods like kimchi
i've been eating kimchi like it's some
[ __ ] medicine for me and it's the
very reason why i haven't you were
eating kimchi like it's medicine
no like i do see it has like i need
probiotics or whatever you know gut
health or whatever i'm eating like
thinking like i'm gonna cleanse my gut
or whatever
and it actually causes me to have uh
eczema because of the fermentation in it
and so it's for are you for sure it's
because of fermentation well then
alcohol
alcohol is also another thing that has
fermentation for inflammation right yeah
yeah so histamines are yeah histamines
is what is found in fermentation
try a sugar elimination diet because
that was the best thing that would do
well he doesn't even consume a lot of
sugar for um
eczema well we don't eat sugars in
everything
like if you just look at the label like
sriracha has sugar like
everything has sugar and if you cut that
out
that's true see what the hell happens
you lose a lot of weight too
hell yeah like just naturally mm-hmm you
are looking pretty
looking fine this is this is good look
at this perm right
fingers dude i actually wanted to get a
perm because of joe honestly
i don't have a perm yeah but i'm jealous
of your wavy hair
and like the oh yeah asian asian hair is
not very weird yeah it's like
i also got wavy hair nelson got wavy
nelson has really wavy hair ryan's got
wavy air yeah actually
a lot of people in this office got way
back you guys got wavy hair and it's
like cool you know and like i just got
wavy hair her hair is pretty sure
oh i straightened it but it naturally is
wavy true why your hair is super
straight
super straight and then now that i'm
getting older too it's like kind of
like it's thinner than it used to be not
that i'm like balding or anything or
not that i have receding hairline or
anything but it's like it's thinning out
and i feel like the hair strands have a
different texture now where
they don't they don't like they don't
bounce yeah it doesn't bounce like your
version of female tits
yes they're droopy thin hair drooping i
don't know
can i try yeah i don't know why i said
female tits like there's any other
colors
it feels a little thinner after he
permed it because it like
with the chemicals it's kind of like
bleaching once you bleach it ends up
like making your hair a little thinner
for some reason i don't know the science
behind it but
for for your hair it did actually get
thinner but more manageable and more
texturized and
the the perming actually helps yeah oh
it's it's it's uh
i think fine is the word not thin right
right you're calling casey fine
yeah fine ass casey so fun
do you want to be fine or you want to be
thick
[Laughter]
your hair looks similar to anthony's uh
level of like fine
yeah fine you're trying to say
fine is definitely the word you're
getting on it damn fine fine ass bro
fine let's get a perm joe you wanna get
a perm i'm down
let's check it out let's see what it's
about oh my gosh can you do the korean
yes can you do the korean curls
please i want a jerry curl if you're
long enough i think you can do it yeah
but how long does it last
dude that would look really good like a
jericho master personality
very much so next episode i'm gonna put
on a wig
and then you guys can oh yeah we do have
uh i'll show you
guys the next episode he's like next
episode i'll put on some socks
good luck finding anything any anything
in there because that's
[ __ ] messing and look for isaac's
photo because he modeled
all the the jk wigs when he was little
and then i printed him out and so he has
like all of the bags that have the wigs
inside it's isaac's face modeling each
wig
it's so [ __ ] cute that's what we need
to be showing when you have isaac come
out here
and put all these in different ways no
he's too old now that he's older
yeah yeah yeah how old is he now 12.
he's he's getting all insecure about
like weird things
oh yeah a little bit of that like emo
teenager kind of like thing going on
with his hair right
yeah yeah for a while he had like this
is the quarantine he just didn't care
yeah it looked like it was one thing
that kind of covers half of one eye
oh for sure and he just feel like yeah
that was my jam yeah
right pull the hair back behind the ear
housing
hey honestly i feel like that's every 12
13 14 years old recently he's been
playing around like he says he's playing
around with like sagging his pants a bit
i'm just playing around i'm like dude we
are reverting back to when we were kids
like how far is the sag though
oh like barely like right above because
right now right now it's like the show
your underwear sag right it's like
supreme and all that stuff right
right but before we used to have like
the knitted you know flannel boxers
how did you guys keep it up yeah you had
to keep on like spread a little bit wait
you had baggy pants
a little bit and no not no not well i
tried i experimented as well play it
played around with it yeah
and you kind of have to like waddle
there's like a there's a walk to do
holding this christmas pumpkin i used to
be this
everyone in my high school when they
would sag they would always wear
basketball shorts on there
right and it would literally be under
under the butt cheeky yeah it was like
boxers basketball shorts
then the pants and then like some sort
of i think it's a fail you couldn't find
it huh i think you used it last that's
why
oh it's your cup if you use anything
it's gone forever it
never gets put back see that's not that
bad come back up
i think it's okay are you sagging right
now what he's done about he can't help
exactly oh so we should be able to why
are you showing your butt cheeks
oh jesus we want to see that's what
people want to see
you girls is it like an attractive thing
well it's not an isolated thing where
i'm like oh
i think the whole package is what i
would look at oh with the jansport
backpack all the way up
yeah super tight way down no you got it
over your ass yeah and you would sign
your friend's backpack
only one strap too with whiteout what
one strap
yeah one strap that's good too that's
swag that was the style
i heard that girls like uh when you sag
and your pants are just
around your ankles and you pee like this
you lift your shirt up
oh you put it over your head
that's how i pee i don't know how about
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
foreign